great white sharks
is there any sea beast so feared by
humans
great whites like these here off the
coast of South Africa in an area called
false Bay can reach 20 feet in length
and weigh up to 5,000 pounds
that's more than a pickup truck but
slightly less than a luxury SUV add this
to the fact that great whites can sprint
through the water it speeds up to 43
miles per hour and it's no wonder we're
afraid of sharks but should we be I mean
let's face it they have great vision
they're curious like cats and they love
to taste things that get their attention
but many scientists believe they don't
like to eat humans they feel about
humans the way most humans feel about
lima beans there's something to eat out
of desperation the fact is great whites
sometimes taste humans for the same
reason they taste other things like
motors or boats they're ampullae of
Lorenzini prompt them to taste it of
course the ampullae of Lorenzini are
gel-filled electro receptors found all
around the Sharks snout and head that's
these smaller pores you see here these
receptors are extremely sensitive to
electrical discharges even as small as
point zero zero five micro volts that
means anything that gives off the
tiniest electrical charge has to be
checked out including all living
creatures in the sea
forget humans and motor boats if you
want to see one great
literally let's talk about ceilings we
know that some whale species engage in
what's called breaching leaping out of
the water but did you know great white
sharks can reach as well look at these
false pay great whites put on a show as
they go after a seal decoy being pulled
by a boat if humans are lima beans to
sharks
then seals are a double hot fudge ice
cream sundae with three cherries on top
luckily we're yeah lima beans